I made two humans I should be able to
take a part of engine just broke again
dude huge thanks to LastPass for
sponsoring a portion of this video you
see this chainsaw right here it probably
looks like a dirty dusty janky old
chainsaw and that's because it is but it
also is something much much more used to
belong to my dad he was a carpenter he
passed away a few years ago and I
inherited all his tools he loved this
chainsaw out of all the tools that he
had this was one of his favorites why
because well you can chop down trees
with a chainsaw
it's just been sitting in my garage not
working rotting away on a shelf but
today that all changes because I've
decided after years I'm gonna restore my
father's old chainsaw I don't think this
chainsaw has run in about 15 years and I
I'm pretty sure it's as old or older
than I am I don't even know who made
this chainsaw made in Canada that's all
it says full disclaimer I am a 100%
complete amateur I follow my own
intuition usually it's not by the way
that your quotes supposed to do things
and none of the things that I do or say
should be taken seriously
maybe I don't know hopefully it just
works everyone who saw the prim tech
video commented about how you shouldn't
start chainsaws like this and how you're
supposed to put it on the ground and
then put your foot on the plate and then
say your prayers look people have been
starting chainsaws like this since time
immemorial because that's the only way
that chainsaws were built did you start
it did you not hurt yourself did you
think about safety before you did it
well you did it right there is in the
winters like condensed garage
your own damn fault red there's so much
pine Greta I actually should get the air
compressor this little computer dusters
not doing anything for me
all right air compressor do you see this
spot right here this is where the air
compressor is supposed to be and of
course it's not here because things
constantly get misplaced around here you
know one thing I'll never need to worry
about misplacing again my passwords
that's right because this video is
sponsored by LastPass let me tell you
about it
you see LastPass relieves the burden of
remembering passwords well still
allowing you to keep track of them all
so you don't have to rewrite be sad we
do we remember answer questions about
your grandma and grandpa no it just
makes it all real simple in one place so
you can stay sane LastPass auto fills
your credentials through cross-device
syncing so whether you're on a website
iOS Android doesn't matter LastPass will
automatically fill in your username and
password and make it fast and easy to
log in it's beautiful
now you might be wondering things like
how many passwords can I keep on
LastPass and is it really actually
secure well actually you can keep
unlimited amounts of passwords on there
and it can be so secure that through a
process of encryption LastPass won't
even know your passwords so if you guys
are interested in simple secure and
convenient password protection click the
link in the description below to find
out more about LastPass now back to that
chain saw
- why is it here
[Applause]
I got it I finally took this apart and
got down to the bare bones you see this
little black plastic piece right there
this is the part that actually broke off
of the button and this copper clip
connects to this which then tells the
spark plug when to give a spark and then
need to epoxy this piece that completes
the circuit and then while it dries
there's a perfect opportunity to clean
all of the metal casting for the body of
the chainsaw that ain't gonna come up
with a screwdriver the nice thing about
metal tools with small engines you take
care of them
the last really long time it's gonna
last until the engine dies my dad took
really good care of his tools that's cuz
he was constantly on job sites you know
at all of his tools were organized
cleaned labeled all of that all the time
all right let's hose it down I mean
that's a pretty big improvement from
where we started
that all right as you can see the parts
are much much much cleaner also our
start/stop button is currently setting
so well that finishes and these parts
dry I'm gonna go take a look at the
engine ok I made two humans I mean I
should be able to take a part of engine
right my only concern is that having
never done this before I don't know if
I'll be able to put it all back for
those of you who are not very familiar
with combustion engines spark plugs on
the top which create a spark inside of
the combustion chamber then the piston
goes in here goes up and down these are
to radiate heat coming from the piston
going up and down and then that causes
some motor to turn I almost just popped
open the motor I'm just gonna visually
inspect this I can hear the compression
motor having compression is the first
step to making sure that it's going to
work at all means that the piston is
causing a proper amount of pressure
which then creates the power for this to
turn everything else runs from that it's
got that good suction well that's dirty
that's where the explosion happens you
want the inside of it to be butter
smooth you don't want any particles or
scratches or dents or anything like that
in there that is also not good
upon visual inspection it looks like
there's just some grime if I clean it
put it all back together seal it
properly it should work just fine
[Music]
chainsaw in there dude this is
that I have no idea what I'm doing then
you haven't been paying attention
alright I cleaned off these motor pieces
they look pretty dang good
check out the piston head remember that
and good as new dude doesn't even smell
like garage anymore a little bit more
degreasing new gaskets new spark plug
real miracle will be if I'm able to
actually put it back together and have
it work
alright day four working on the chainsaw
the trigger is finally cured and
functional it seems so simple first
things first I have to put this back
together then put it back on everything
else goes on around it that's it
everything is back then we have no extra
parts lying around let's put up with
some gas let's go find this out you Nick
Oh God that's not good I keep hearing
scratching that's not good that's the
piston going can we give him more
stubborn than it he brings up a really
good point in order to get a chainsaw to
start you need to be more stubborn since
the chainsaw got here that slipping
speaking of language so I flooded it
plus I don't even know if the spark plug
is sparking I'll call my buddy ask him
for advice if I can't fix it I'll just
send it to him that would be a real
disappointment I feel like I need to fix
it I mean maybe you can just give you
advice and you can do I hope you can
walk you through it okay I'm still not
sure whether or not the spark plug is
causing a spark inside of this little
engine here so there is a way to test
that with this an inline spark tester
the spark plug is in fact causing a
spark this will light up and then we
know that that's not the problem if that
is the problem it means there's
something wrong with the electric
starter
and now that's that's really an area
that's beyond my level of knowledge
probably need to send it out I hope
that's not the profit I really want this
thing to run
okay so yeah there's no spark ouch
yeah okay well that's probably why it's
not starting now you just double-check
this like on another thing that I know
that works here's the thing about dads
they see the potential of what things
can be they see the potential in you
that you don't see in yourself when
you're when you're younger do you think
your dad so that potential coming out
and you well he saw the potential he
didn't see the result though I was like
28 when he passed away I'm starting to
like starting to become a man a little
bit but you know at that age you're
still kind of you're kind of young but I
don't know I think he was pretty proud
of us because he honestly he did he did
a lot worse than I did as a young man so
we know the tester works I just need to
verify that in fact I'm not getting any
spark ah god damn it this is the exact
same thing I'm gonna tell my son the
hell's wrong with you do this watch for
a little spark
[Music]
oh my god yes dude you don't give up
you'll win eventually
should I almost had it are you facing
north when you pulled it hmm it might be
a more of like a southern chainsaw you
try facing south
[Music]
now we just need to change
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone in the studio I'm gonna make
them their own spirit animal out of wood
eagle cuz you got your spider monkey I
will make you the best version that I
can of that animal out of wood with a
chainsaw is gonna be a dog
I believe Sam's a wolf what's your
spirit animal